hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
[Music]
just checking in on you
i'm just checking in to see how your
week
is going
how's it going with you
what do you say
what do you do
um
i'm having a good week the old covid
[__] bug
[__] finally got me oh jesus
the messed up [__] they finally took you
down
yeah um
somebody some kid at school got it gave
it to kids and my kid brought it home i
mean what was i supposed am i supposed
to [__] walk around my house you know
walking in a hazmat suit
and i gotta tell you
you know i feel i feel great
this this omicron i guess isn't that bad
thank god i didn't get the other [__]
the other [__] with people like [__]
face down with swords on their faces or
whatever the [__] was going on
um so i'm sitting there going like all
right so i guess
what they're saying is a vaccine
is working on some level because i'm not
really sick i got a little scratchiness
that's it it's not really a vaccine as
much as it's like a shot it's like the
flu shot right
that's another thing too is then i
started looking up all of this stuff
because i haven't paid attention to
anything i was just like on the news he
like wear a mask stay six feet away from
people and i was like perfect i've been
doing that my whole life minus the mask
i don't like people quarantining got it
i am the man for that job
so i almost went two [__] yes i had a
nice run
um yeah so i got to give a shout out to
doctors because i think it it's not as
bad
because i know some people got it
they're all [__] up and uh
i feel great i mean i'm still smoking
cigars and playing drums to be honest
with you
um and now i have an excuse to not
[__]
go to work
this reminds me when i got hit by a car
when i was a kid i remember it happened
on a wednesday and the doctor goes yeah
you shouldn't go to school for the rest
of the week and it was so [__]
awesome
because i didn't i had a four day
weekend and i didn't have to [__] uh
i didn't have to fake sick
it was great i told you that story
before the only thing that sucked was
the car hit me right on the side of my
head surprise surprise little dumb dumb
billy
um
if you put your your fingers on this on
the side of your head and bite down on
your uh your lower back teeth you feel
that thing going in and out
feel that whatever the [__] that is that
was the only thing
because i got hit right there and it
hurt to eat so i remember i was eating
raisin bran with a really little spoon
other than that i was hanging out i was
watching the prices right
so
anyway um all my unvaxxed friends are
going dude go take the irmekton so i
looked this [__] up
and you know it's [__] hilarious on
the uh
what the [__] is it the uh
who the [__] are they
caa what's the name of the people that
fdc fcc
the fda or whatever when you look up
ivormectin they have a picture of a
woman in scrubs walking a horse because
they keep saying
that it's for horses and then i just
looked up where can you buy it and it
says cvs and walgreens
i mean what the f i mean
there is just so much [__]
misinformation out there i just i don't
i'm not going to pay attention
you know i can't remember ever going
into a cvs and seeing a horsey [__]
walking up and down the aisle you know
what the ivor mechtin is
um
[Laughter]
but anyway
aside from the scratchy throat and the
occasional cough i feel [__] fine
everybody's doing fine so
uh it is what it is
i guess uh one of those i don't want to
start saying the people's names in this
story
you know fouchy i guess they were saying
that everyone was gonna get the omicron
so
um whatever i fought a brave battle man
i fought a brave [__] battle
um so here i sit
um but now i don't know who to believe
about i still think what i did was right
i think what everybody's doing is right
who gives a [__] i think we're all gonna
[__] meet in the middle and this
thing will gradually die out
right isn't that what's gonna happen
i don't
know i will tell you when this whole
thing goes away i will miss the masks
that's literally how [__] anti-social
i am i love it
you put a hat on sunglasses and a
[__] mask i mean you're ready to go
rob a bank
i'm surprised more banks haven't been
[__] robbed
isn't that amazing i mean i would put an
idea in somebody's head but you can
literally walk into a bank dress like a
bank robber and they just think you're
being responsible
and then all you got to do is you just
slide the n i love how you can rob a
bank with a note
and just hey man give me the money
well you're not going to like what i do
next
i would love to write back well would
you like to give me an example can you
brandish a weapon or something
what do you got halitosis what what what
am i dealing with here on the other side
of this bulletproof glass
it'd be funny you know if you just if
you were like
if you had like a gambling problem you
worked at a bank
like that philip seymour hoffman
movie that i could not get through i
have still have to finish that movie it
was so gut-wrenching to watch this guy
[__] his life up
um
if you uh
if you if you would like like a gambler
right
if you're a gambler
and you [__] uh
you're working the bank right you're a
teller jesus christ bill
you're a bank teller right and the guy
comes up
and he's he passes the letter you know
hey give me all the money or uh you know
something bad's gonna happen
you kind of look at him
you know like world series of poker
like here comes the river right you
decide to call his bluff
you know
and you just write back
and you just say [__] what i got
on the other side of this glass
is gonna kill you and your whole [__]
family just i don't know some sort of
gangster [__] you slide it back
also so why don't your best [__]
your best move right now
is to take this piece of paper
and walk out of this [__] bank
and go panhandle for a sandwich
because if you don't
you're going to spend the rest of your
life trying not to take a dick in the
ass
believe that
sincerely tell her number 764 and just
slide it back or if you just once
give me all the money just wrote back
[__] you slid it back to him and just
stare at him
[Music]
what if they had suicidal people as
tellers like the amount of money that
banks could [__]
could save
you know what i mean because they would
just be like yeah i don't give a [__] do
whatever you want
oh no you're supposed to be all afraid
and then uh give me the money and then i
it's like buddy listen i know you're not
armed because armed robbery if you get
caught
is a much stiffer sentence
coming here like a [__] pen pal
hey is there any like bitcoin banks
can you go and rob those let me see let
me look that up
let's add to the ignorance of my [__]
search
my internet searches here
by the way i already talked about this
on the anything better podcast because
when i was doing the monday
morning podcast that chief's bills game
was still going was that that was the
most atrocious defense
i have seen
it was an unbelievable excitement
watching the offense but afterwards i
was thinking like
like that was [__] horrible
i wonder what ray lewis thought if he
was watching that game with jack lambert
they probably think like what the [__]
has happened to this game these these
two teams are playing to go to the afc
championship game this is what the [__]
it is you know what the precursor to
that that the foreshadowed
you know all these [__] rule changes
and [__]
because i think the nfl is trying to
keep up with the nba because all they do
is shoot three pointers
was the the the patriots eagles super
bowl
well the eagles won the super bowl while
letting up five over 500 yards passing
you let up over 500 yards passing yeah
we didn't even notice
that didn't even hurt us
unreal all right
bitcoin
bank
robbed
rob robbery no nothing but no robbery
the great bitcoin bank robbery
oh hacking bitcoin
oh god
it's gonna get me on some sort of watch
list here
oh look it's got a b on it for bitcoin
what is it made out of by the way is
that any sort of precious metal or is it
just supposed to look like gold
i love this whole [__] bitcoin hey
our ponzi scheme is better than the
ponzi scheme that you're currently in
uh
sean everett wasn't sure how his bullish
bet on cryptocurrency would turn out but
he definitely didn't expect it to be
over so soon in march he sold all his
stocks including apple and amazon and
used a chunk of the proceeds to buy
bitcoin
and
ethereum on a site called coinbase the
decision made everett the ceo of
artificial intelligence startup prom
almost instantly richer
as the blockbuster chain
jesus christ
this is why i'm not into money
what happened
i'm not reading all this
jesus christ
you know someday when i get old i'm
going to write a [__] history book
after i talk to people when they tell me
what happened and i'm just going to
write what happened
the american revolution
the british were [__]
and then they lost
that's what happened
if you really want to get into the
minutia read another [__] book
or minutia
however you say it um so
anyway
um
i went on a flight a few weeks ago man
that i cannot stop [__] thinking
about
i'm really really starting
you know people who's kidding who all
right
now that meatloaf died i am one of the
older entertainers out there okay
you know god bless meatloaf rest in
peace absolute [__]
beast
of a performer absolute [__] beast
of a performer and what i love about
that guy was that guy was not supposed
to make it
any
there's no [__] way the music
industry was not looking for that dude
ever they're still not looking for that
dude but despite that that [__] dude
came out
did his thing
and sold tens of millions
of [__] albums and
i never saw him in concert and everybody
said
you know
i can't believe he never died during one
of his concerts how hard that guy went
like tom jones [__] just [__] drip
and sweat right
so anyway
you know you know the internet somebody
dies somebody has to make a joke
somebody wrote the funniest [__] joke
this dude said uh
he said he went on meatloaf's wikipedia
page and he said
that the guy said one of the hardest
things
for me in life has been trying to get
respect
in the music business
and this
person on twitter wrote
yo
he goes you called yourself meatloaf my
dude
rest in peace you crazy bastard
i mean that's like one of the [__]
that's one of my favorite things in life
you know
when you're sitting there complaining
or feeling sorry for yourself and then
just somebody comes with the answer
and it's so true
it's just funny and all you have to do
is just you can just laugh
you know jimmy dore did that for me one
time
one time i was talking to him
there was some chick in my acting
classes check i was just [__] you
know
fell head over heels in love with her
and i was such a walled off psycho you
know i've just [__] loved it the
second i saw her right
and uh whatever years later
i'm talking to jimmy dore right
and i was single at the time and
everything
he was single or whatever we were just
talking about women
and he's like you ever have a woman
break your heart and i was like yeah
yeah
i was talking about this chick and he
goes oh yeah how did you go out with her
and i was like now
i go i never even talked to her
and he literally stopped walking
because i built a whole relationship in
my head it's easy to fall in love with
somebody you never talk to because they
can't like
you know they always they're perfect in
your mind right
so when he found out i had never even
talked to her
he [__] i remember i still remember
we were somewhere in the
like i don't know
18th street or 20th street or some [__]
in new york
and he was literally leaning on a
mailbox he was laughing so hard
just dying laughing at me
and he was laughing so hard i was like
what
what he goes
and he was like just going you fell in
love with a chick
that you never even talked to
and i said yeah
and he laughed even harder for like
another 30 seconds
and he was laughing so hard he got me
going i didn't know he's laughing about
it i go what what he goes bill
he goes
for all you know she could have been a
[__] right and i just [__] bursted
out laughing
and i really never thought about her
again he just so put it into perspective
and that joke took me to that
you called yourself meatloaf my dude
there you go
how do you sell that
and that's what i loved about meatloaf
because he looked the way he did he
didn't look like a rock star
he's [__] overweight and he called
himself meatloaf and he [__]
that doesn't make any [__] sense and
he did it
the [__] dude did it so god bless him
um
yeah this was a sad week and i also have
to give a shout out to one of the
greatest stand-up comics
i ever saw uh the great louis anderson
um
i still remember when that hbo special
that half hour he did or did he do an
hour i can't remember
and um
what is so amazing to me about that
special is was he was a [__] master
already
like
i think i looked it up the one that i
was looking up
um i want to say that a black sports
coat and a red shirt or something like
that i can't remember but he was already
a master and he was in still in his
early 30s
and he had that
that bill cosby
pacing
first of all totally clean
and he had that relaxed
storytelling and he could literally do
like
you know
he could just like
move his face or glance over or
something he would get like an applause
break and people laughing and he just
got everything out of every laugh
just with absolute master and i'll never
forget the first time i met him
um
i think it was my first like tv gig it
was louis anderson's comedy
showcase
and years later i found out that that's
where dice clay did one of his specials
i forget what the [__] theater was
called it was right across from capitol
records it's called like the avalon now
or something like that
but um
i remember oh man they shot it during
the day
it was one of those things they shot it
during the day and they just had gotten
tourists off of hollywood boulevard like
half a block away and brought these
people in and they were just sitting
there like what the [__] going on and
people were [__] eating it or only
doing okay as you i mean it was
literally like
i mean i sometimes i felt like i got
there like 10 in the morning and i went
on at like 1 30 in the afternoon to do a
tv
thing and um
i went out there and was just like all
right man just [__] get him on that
first one and
[__] get through this thing and
somehow um
i got him on the first one and i
actually had i mean i didn't have a
great set it's my first one ever but i
got through it i had a really good set
and i remember he came walking and he
goes keep it going fibbiliever you know
he talks and then he looked at me
because you're gonna be a big star
i remember then i was like oh my god
that's amazing i can't believe he's
probably just being nice but that was
awesome
and then i never saw him again
for years
and then one day i was out in l.a i
don't know if it's what after i moved
out here and 07 sometime in the 2000s i
ran into him i was in the back and he
came walking in the main room you know
green room and i immediately felt like i
had no right to be there because he came
walking in
and he just came walking he just goes
hey hey bill how are you he just sat
down and talked to me
as though i was a peer
and i i can't even tell you how what a
thrill it was that he even knew who the
[__] i was
and he was just so nice and that's just
how he was over the years he just was
always
you know
one of the best out there doing it while
also being one of the nicest people ever
and um
i don't know that's one of the ones that
starts to make me think there is a god
you know
because he keeps taking all the nice
people sag it
took saggitt and uh louis anderson this
month
you know
yet here i sit still living though
[Laughter]
anyways rest in peace louie anderson um
just one of the greats to ever do it if
you're a young comic
and
you think you go too fast which i still
think i do
that is a guy to watch
and study
because
i'm telling you man that guy had
mastered this [__]
by the time he was like 33 or 34. he
just
that guy you came out there
you were locked in and he just took you
on the ride man that guy
amazing and um
another amazing amazing person comedians
i'm telling you we get a bad rap a lot
of us we're good guys
we're good guys you wouldn't know you
wouldn't know it with all this crap
that's out there about us but we uh
we're all right
um
so i was actually thinking um
whenever i get a little
overwhelmed with my work i always have
this reoccurring like dream
you know what i mean
like uh you ever see that movie sexy
beast where the guy keeps having that
nightmare that [__]
sort of half man half bull devil thing
i i don't have a nightmare i have like a
dream whenever i get like too busy i
just have this dream that i live in the
middle of nowhere
you know and it's super quiet like right
now when i picture it it's out in the
desert
but it's usually in the woods
i just live in the middle of nowhere
and for some reason my kids don't suffer
you know with no friends in a shitty
local education
you know
that's the only thing about you know
there's always a price
you know you live in a city
you know there's all these amazing
people all these different cultures all
this different kind of food
all of these different perspectives all
of these museums
all this cosmopolitan [__] but then you
got to just deal with the fact that
you're stacked up like sardines
you got to deal with crime you got to
deal with just
craziness right
but
then you live in the middle of nowhere
and you solve all of that
you're not stacked up like sardines you
got fresh air
there's a place to park
that's my thing
there's a driveway
you know every driveway out here in
[__] l.a is just it's [__]
hilarious
they're all [__]
curved and all of that unless you buy
like a brand new house my dumbass i
always
always liked old [__] right so my
driveway's made for like a [__] model
t ford
um
so
be a place to park and all that but then
i would just have to deal
with all these [__] weirdo neighbors
at least maybe that's why they live away
from each other
you know
because that is the thing when you you
live by yourself when you isolate you
slowly go [__] crazy but you know in
defense of people live in the middle of
nowhere you can also do that in a city
where um i don't see it as much in la
because you're sort of forced to kind of
go out a little bit
get in your car and go drive and do [__]
but like the [__]
weirdos
that i saw when i lived in new york city
like those [__] lifer new yorkers
like oh man you're not getting out are
you
i used to see these [__] people
you know they always talk about like the
cat people and that type of [__] i'm not
talking about them i just mean like
i'm just talking like little old [__]
people you're just looking at like do
you have anybody is there anybody taking
care of you how can you be around all of
these people and like it's like like
nobody even sees you
um
[Music]
they have [__] old clothes
this is getting depressing i know but
this was like the [__] i would see and i
would think like
i got to get out of the city i'm not
going to be that
you know
everybody like all the old people like
they all look like they look like lou
reed or look like they were in the
ramones at some point
you know when they stayed at the party
too [__] long
you know either that or they have they
walk down the street like wearing the
estate jewelry that's going to be going
up for auction soon
all right it got a little dark let me
let me read some of the advertising here
for this week um
where are we
all right
is this it
yeah all right missing in maine
everybody
you know don't you feel like you are
just
never excited about wearing a dress
shirt
um no i like wearing a button-down shirt
intro
that's why you got to check out mizzen
and maine mr domain combines the comfort
and flexibility of your favorite
athletic wear with the fitness style of
a custom dress shirt that's what the
[__] i'm talking about
i like that lightweight breathable and
moisture wicking
missing in moisture wicking that is big
that is big i learned that last week
trying to buy a thermal we don't have
that but we have moisture wicking
material
um mizzen and maine's clothing will have
you
looking great wouldn't it be great if
you could wear a shirt to a wedding or a
funeral and not feel like you're wearing
a straight jacket
plus their dress shirt our mach dress
shirts are machine wash washable so you
can skip those trips to the dry cleaner
oh my god did i find my new stand-up
shirts i think i just did think of all
the time and money you'll save on a hot
day in washington dc mission and maine's
founder saw a guy running up the hill in
a sweat soaked wrinkled dress shirt and
thought there had to be a better way
since then they've set out to make
being comfortable and looking great the
new normal
um
they may have gotten famous for their
dress shirt but mizzen main now makes
incredibly comfortable flannels no tuck
shirts performance polos chinos and so
much more all in performance fabrics
with modern tailoring with mizzen and
main it's never
felt better to look your best and
they've got over thirty thousand five
star reviews so you know they make a
great product
um whether you're working from the golf
course or taking a or a golf course or
taking conference calls in the courtyard
we've got good news right now if you go
to mizzonmain.com use the promo code
burr you'll receive 35 dollars off any
regular price order for 125 or more
that's 35 off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n
um dot-com m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n
missing in maine.com and use the promo
code burr
all right who do you got here it's
policy genius
policy genius um get your property
cold weather ready by making sure you
have the right insurance coverage check
the link in the description or head to
policygenius.com and answer a few
questions about yourself and your
property policy genius will show you
price estimates for policies that fit
your search
and help you understand your options the
policy genius team can look for ways to
save you more money and if they find a
better rate than what you're paying now
they'll switch it over for free policy
genius has saved new customers an
average of 350 dollars per year on home
insurance the policy genes team works
for you not insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help and
advocate
uh
for you at every step until you're
covered policy genius doesn't add on
extra fees palsy genius doesn't sell
your info to third parties policy genius
top-notch service has earned them
thousands of five-star reviews across
google and trustpilot since 2014 policy
genius has helped over 30 million people
shop for insurance and placed 120
billion in coverage head to
policygenius.com to get your home and
auto insurance quotes and see how much
you could save
all right
simply safe
simply safe uh if you've ever wanted to
make sure
or make your home feel safer there is no
better time than now right now our
friends at simply safe are giving my
listeners across all their new year's
holiday deals 20 off award-winning home
security and your first month is free
when you sign up
uh for the interactive monitoring
service i love simply safe because it
has everything you need
to make your home feel safe indoor and
outdoor cameras compress comprehensive
sensors all monitored around the clock
by trained professionals who send help
the instant you need it you can easily
customize a system for your home online
in minutes and even get free custom
recommendations there are no long-term
contracts or commitments it's really a
really easy way to start feeling a bit
more peace of mind in the new year hurry
take 20 off your simply safe system
uh hurry to take 20 off your simply safe
system and your first month is free when
you sign up for the interactive
monitoring service visit simply safe.com
again that's simply safe
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash burr
for 20 off your entire
system
all right how much time have i done here
oh look at that right up on it i got 15
minutes to eat lunch and i'm right back
onto another zoom meeting
cause my life never ends
my business day i should say
anyway that is the part that's not the
podcast we got the oh we got the bed mgm
segment coming up right now
with me and the wonderful paul version
andrew femilis talking about last week's
playoff games and uh giving you some of
our
telling you what we're going to be
gambling on uh
in the afc and nfc championship game and
here it is what's up everybody and
welcome back to the anything better
podcast nfl edition uh sponsored of
course by bet mgm and we are going into
championship week guys as you know all
football season the anything better
podcast has teamed up with bet mgm okay
we've teamed up with them they have the
best most reliable lines uh we've been
using them
for every one of our picks and we also
have special offers for our listeners if
you haven't signed up to bet mgm yet
it's very simple use bonus code bur
b-u-r-r you'll get 200 free after
placing your first 10 bet here's how it
works you download the bet mgm app okay
it's simple i actually did it during
football it took me two minutes you use
bur b-u-r-r you place your first 10
money line bet put your money down on
any nfl game here's the thing any game
10 bucks you'll receive 200 in free bets
immediately after placing your bet
regardless of the outcome i'm gonna
repeat that regardless of the outcome
you understand that means the [__]
monkey could take a [__] dart throw
it at a board and you [__] it it's
risk-free all right that's how simple
this is so just make sure you use bonus
code burr when you sign up have fun be
responsible and use bed mgm it's the
most reliable lines now bill before we
get into championship week i need the
floor i just need the floor for a minute
okay
i need the floor for a minute because
i've been stewing in this
for if so so and then and then it's
yours and then i will [__] defer to
you okay unlike the [__] opportunity
unlike the opportunity the bills had but
let's get into this i am done
i am done i am done i am done
with the green bay packers i am done
with them going 13 and three in the
regular season
i'm done with them going 15-1 in the
regular season aaron rodgers mvp he's
the goat he does this he does that and
then a team that doesn't play in that
weather from the west coast comes in
there beats him okay eli went in there
beat him when they were 15 and one i'm
[__] done i apologize to everybody
when i brady went in last year beat him
i mean everybody beats him that's what
the packers do great regular season they
stink they [__] stink when it counts
all right and i got to tell you
something
aaron rodgers peyton manning i don't
want him in the big game i don't want
him in the big game i'll take [__]
eli manning over those [__] guys i'm
done all right and here's the other
thing i don't want to hear
oh
that these games were great
cooper cups should not be open in that
game okay the [__] safeties weren't
there it was terrible defense the bills
and packers made me sick i'm sorry i'm
[__] done go bill go
i know once the once the uh the elation
of watching the excitement at the end of
those games that was some of the most
atrocious
defense and special teams
i've seen that they were all playing
like two and 14 teams
how are you on the on the defense of the
bills or the chiefs and at the end when
the whole team's celebrating what is the
defense doing
yeah yeah yeah we did it
i mean they were getting smoked
awful 25 points in the final [__] two
minutes
i'll tell you what broke my heart was
watching tom brady yet again
drives him down for the [__] go ahead
or whatever just to watch his [__]
team blow it how many [__] times
twice against those goddamn giants
well he tom brady did everything he
could josh allen did everything he could
these guys and then all of us how the
[__] do you get how did they [__] allen
did it like three [__] times and they
still couldn't put him to bed how do you
get 60 yards in 13 seconds from the
25-yard line i mean how the [__] what
kind of prevent defense is that where is
that i think too and they were they were
blaming the coach going they should have
kicked somebody to to run the seconds
because because 13 seconds
is too much [__] time now
it's that's it's like how about this 13
seconds
and you're the [__] number one
defense in the [__] nfl
and there's another thing that's
[__] too they're definitely gonna
change the rule
okay regular season who first touchdown
wins over time come on we gotta get on
with that live playoffs playoffs get me
you can't just one guy gets the ball and
that's it that's [__] stupid
because whoever won that coin toss was
gonna go down there and win it
i get that i get that and i think you're
right but that being said can somebody
make a stop can buffalo see what their
quarterback did and make a [__] stop
i mean the kid [__] played incredible
i mean you could say the same about the
chiefs the same thing
[__] unbelievable man you know what
was bugging me was when josh allen was
driving down the field he threw an
incomplete pass i saw kelsey on the
sideline he goes
does the stupid mutombo thing and then
he scores a [__] touchdown
then he scores a [__] touch and it's
like like i just didn't when he's going
like this it's like kelsey what game are
you watching
yeah your defense stinks they're gonna
score
yeah
yeah wow now i got to tell you this paul
stafford's got to have the game of his
life but i think the rams
i don't know the rams the rams the rams
could stop those guys
for the love of god
but but i will say this though patrick
mahomes might be so mobile
i don't know that's a that's an
incredible matchup because it used to be
like a front floor like that your giants
used to get tom brady would get him
moving but tom couldn't run mahomes can
he runs a little dainty but the man
definitely runs
i just don't understand how you don't
take cooper cup out of a game or at
least contain him same thing with tyree
kill tyree kill was the one to get that
[__] thing in the at the end tyreek
hill was the one to get there it's like
you just irikil's the only one i'll give
him a pass on
that guy is like he's not even [__]
dude the guy was running down the
sideline he gave the peace sign to a
professional athlete
like he was driving by in a car
i mean tyreke hill is just like
that guy's terrifying
he's everybody else is human out there
that [__] guy
is warp speed
i mean that was that was ridiculous
dude i'm not even a buffalo bills fan
and the the hurt that i felt for josh
allen after what that guy did
it's it's dude somebody said i think it
was stephen a smith somebody goes that
defense should be ashamed of itself
after what that guy [__] did and he's
right that guy [__] just sat there
when they lost like what else could i do
here's the thing don't ever feel bad for
their fans though
don't ever feel bad for a fan base what
you're looking at is a dormant volcano
and all it needs is a [__]
championship and they will instantly
become [__] well i feel bad for they
were [__] [__] when they kept
winning the afc east and the afc
championship before they started once
they lost two super bowls in a row they
kind of had to shut up a little bit but
they were [__] when they were the
run and gun thurman thomas jim kelly
fred smirless
uh bruce smith
cornelius bennett
daryl talley
daryl oh you got me uh
uh bibby
um all right yeah that their fan base
were [__] the same thing it's like oh
the patriots the most obnoxious [__]
fans ever yeah we're we're about as
obnoxious as anybody would be
if if you won that much so i'm not gonna
sit there be like oh there's poor people
you know they spend their hard-earned
money on tables
i'm just i'm not buying it
and what are the green bay packers doing
fighting for that home field and getting
it and getting the buy and rogers is
healthy what are you doing what do you
got a guy six foot four 228 blocking a
guy's six four 270 right up the gut
guy was giving away [__] 42 pounds
you can't get mad at that packers guy
that was a heavyweight versus super
heavyweight
well let's see he's gonna figure out a
way to get it done all these [__] fat
[__] can't even put their socks on
without breathing heavy i'm gonna say
what that kid should have been doing
well i'll tell you this
how about i give joe burrow credit for
getting sacked nine times
joe burrow got sacked nine times it's
your playoff record and still found a
way to [__] win that game on the road
man
i love joe burrow but you know what
there was a couple of those he could
have thrown it away his instinct is to
talk and start scrambling backwards like
fran tarkington and he's not fast he
shouldn't be he's gonna when he gets
that out of his game he's only gonna get
sacked six times paul that kid's got a
little yeah he it comes from heart but
yeah you're right um all right so let's
get to these championship games we got
the cincinnati
i mean paul he lets cooper cup get
parallel with them before he turns and
tries to start running with them
i couldn't believe it get beat
underneath
fight on the deep route and he breaks it
up and whenever he gets dirty in front
of you you don't let him run by you
i couldn't believe it when i saw cooper
cup run that route and just run past
winfield junior i actually couldn't
[__] believe he just ran to the end
zone he didn't there was no move there
was no stutter step he just [__] ran
and the guy's like oh i guess he's
running
i do that in the yard with my kids i do
that
i believe that's called a go route
[Laughter]
um they drew that up in the dirt it was
just a straight line to the [__] goal
post
i'm gonna run straight throw a bomb uh
got the cincinnati bagels going into
where because assistant they are going
into the arrowhead stadium against the
chiefs can joe burrow shock the world
can joe burrow shock the world in the
afc championship game
chris wait i got a question for you does
a good defense
beat a good offense anymore
i remember years ago when we watched the
[__] patriots eagles and i remember
watching that game going dude if this is
what the future of the nfl is
because nobody when i was watching that
game by the third quarter i said to my
buddy because they there was no punts
until the end of the third quarter i was
like i don't know who's going to win
this game but nobody on defense should
get a [__] ring you should get a ring
because you got there but you should
have one less [__] diamond i mean
that was a joke that was that was a
video game the winning defense let up
over 500 yards passing and got a [__]
they got a ring
they even might be the champions that
game reminded me of playing madden with
my friends and everybody just goes
forward on fourth down every time
because it doesn't matter that's what
that was
and you get it and you get it oh yeah it
was crazy so my question for you paul is
does a good defense
do those great giant defense teams that
beat the undefeated patriots
beat bill belichick and tom brady the
big [__] rubik's cube nobody could
figure out except for you guys
all right eagles went 50 50. got to give
them a shout out
can your giants
with those [__] super-sized
linebackers in [__] 2008 that i was
so jealous of
and one of them went on to host good
morning america who who knew who knew
you also had the replacement for regis
philbin
hey bill i know
can they stop a gr the way the way the
game has changed and all the rules and
don't touch the quarterback to the point
they can fake slide and run for another
30 yards hey bill i know who can't do it
the [__] packers that's who can't do
it
um here's a deal
they said that cincinnati played the
best defensive game of the year and the
chief's defense stinks the problem that
i saw with cincy man is that offensive
line not protecting him and when you
look at that game film if the chiefs are
all over him and they get behind they're
going to be playing from they're going
to be playing from behind trying to
catch up i worry about boro's protection
dude because it did not look good it did
not look good man yeah and but the
chiefs defense also did not look good so
stinks but i mean
i just think they have too many too many
weapons too much of experience
um what's the idea
andrew what's the line what's the line
on the afc championship game
seven and a half
although the bangladesh bengals have my
new favorite field goal kicker
i don't even know his name but before he
went out there he goes congratulations
we're going to the afc championship game
and i just thought too that people
always like go for it go for it go for
it you see all these [__] field goals
winning games this past weekend
i love a [__] field goal kicker with
ice water in his veins adam vinatieri
first ballot hall of famer
half our super bowl trophies are on his
foot
take out tyreek hill
since he's got a shot
i like cincy with the points
i like i like cincy with the seven and a
half
i like it you know what i want a roof
for cincy so i'll take cincy we're
getting our ass kicked in the playoffs
let's have fun anyways come on yeah we
are getting our ass kicked we're getting
smoked yeah because the mvp doesn't do
what they would let's go 10 points but
it's for 10 points
at home they scored 10 points at home
with a bye week 10. it was too cold paul
they weren't used to playing in the cold
san francisco players go to the beach
i'm [__] go to the beach when they're
off
snowing
it's like it's like 40 degrees in san
francisco that's the funny thing
jimmy garoppolo no no but now they play
inland now they play inland towards uh
san jose so it's actually hot
jimmy garoppolo is with his girlfriend
surfing teaching him how to surf going i
gotta go to lambeau it's gonna be
snowing next week don't worry we'll win
they had to buy we'll win
[__] it's unacceptable jimmy g kept
his chain on during the game and he
still beat him
and i
and i was rooting for rogers i know a
lot of people weren't rooting for rogers
a lot of people don't root for rogers
for a lot of different reasons a lot of
people weren't rooting for rogers
because of covet a lot of people weren't
rooting for rogers because of a lot of
things that he's done the off-season
that he had i was rooting for the guy
who i thought was the most skilled
player on the [__] field i don't care
about off the field [__] but you can't
have a bye week at lambeau field and get
home field and [__] lose again
you can't and somebody said something
and i might take it this far i'm going
to take it this far
oh he's closing the door people he's
going deep now oh
listen to me
this man right here has more listen he
has more playoff yards than anybody
mahomes is 438 yards away from this guy
this guy has gone into hostile
environments and [__] won this guy
over aaron rodgers and peyton manning
any day of the [__] week
well next time your wife gives you [__]
can you please pick up that little thing
and just be like you think this guy lets
his wife talk to him like that do you
because this guy has taken out the trash
more than anybody in this house
i know his face doesn't say it he's got
heart yeah all right all right um
so
so now
we could get into the nfc championship
we got the san francisco 49ers
we got the san francisco 49ers bill
going into wait it's in it's in los
angeles at the rams
matthew stafford
13 years with the lions now has a shot
to go to a super bowl he's got
he's got a good defense he's got going
bill like what's that line
andrew what's that line
uh three three and a half i love it i
love the rams three and a half i think
san francisco stepped in [__] last week
they had that [__] third grader
blocking a fifth grader on the [__]
punt
ended the game
they stole the [__] game out there
and i just you know
listen i think thank you
super bowl i love san francisco i love
their organization i love the punchline
i love that jimmy jesus i love molly at
the punch line but i'll tell you right
now i don't love that football team
against the rams you want to laugh i had
people over for the game and somebody's
like nah dude san fran is not going to
win and they're like i don't know about
this jimmy g guy and jimmy g had his
helmet off and i go yeah i mean it's a
good looking italian kid though can we
be honest
it's just bursting out laughing
um
three and a half is a really good number
uh
i guess i would have to say because of
the defense i agree with you bill i
would say the rams because of the
defense
i think they're gonna kick their ass
you do
yeah
okay
i think stafford's every bit as good as
jimmy g i think they got that [__]
front forward a great d and they got
cooper cup
and he's going to run right up to the
safety right by him and say oh [__]
where's he going it's going to be a
touchdown but don't forget week 18.
you can't forget week 18. why can't i
figure out week 18 because week games i
thought they were in the same division
paul
week 18 the rams were beating the niners
17 nothing and the niners needed the
game to get to the playoffs and they
came back and beat him that was just two
short weeks ago i love it okay and the
patriots beat the giants in [__]
december and then we lost to you a month
later i love it
all right well listen i i gotta go with
the defense defense is what wins i take
the rams too so we are going
listen it hasn't been the greatest it
hasn't been the greatest playoff run for
for the anything better podcast i'll be
the first to admit it hey you know what
it's candy it's it's the buffalo bills
and the packers fault
i'm blaming them um but we will go
cincinnati getting seven and a half
and the rams laying three and a half
against the 49ers
um to go to the super bowl man doesn't
mean we're saying that the chiefs aren't
gonna go but we like the points with
cincy and we think the rams are going
so let's see what let's see can we
finish that up strong um i'll tell you
this though i want to say this for the
record i think if the rams go to the
super bowl against the chiefs
i like the rams because i think the rams
defense will take rams got good d backs
and the chicken
who we hate the chiefs
okay people putting their money down
here come on man you got to be honest
you hate the chiefs
listen a little bit of a of a bias yes
and it's not against chiefs fans i love
chiefs fans
there's a couple things protect your
[__] improv date out there now let's
get down to what you're thinking about
the team
the team annoys me a bit
you
uh
out yeah a little bit i don't know what
it is
all right well i just everything mahomes
does oh my god he threw it sidearm it
drives me up the wall and and i hate
that little lateral it's a little
underhanded that you throw into a
toddler like that and they freak out
i'll tell you they got a lot of looks
down here on the [__] goal line
i never wanted to talk about a guy's
family but here's what bugs me
anytime i see family members
throwing stuff yelling cheering and
yelling at fans whoever it may be a
brother a sister a cousin a wife
oh paul paul where you going with this
one no no as soon as i see family
members of a player getting involved
like that listen i don't mind you saw
josh allen's dad in the box hugging the
mom after he threw this thing i'm all
good with that i'm talking about when
you see family members going like this
like this or like this that's when i'm
like alright you gotta enough enough
enough yeah you're not playing
you're not playing that's what it is my
only thing is it's if
i always feel bad if i see a dude as a
really controlling woman to the point
you know who she is and they keep
cutting to her in the crowd
like remember that basketball guy he had
to go like this before the he shot a
foul shot that meant i love you to his
kids
oh yes yeah there was a certain
quarterback in his is his his wife who
looked like the principal was sitting in
the front row a long time ago i was just
like jesus christ
can the guy have his [__] three hours
of glory
without showing this [__] bride if
you did you ever see that in a wnba game
it's a boyfriend and a wife feeder
sitting there
all right that's it let's let's do our
little uh
parlay
so here we go
all right here's what i like paul i'm
gonna go no surprises okay
i like joe mixon to get a touchdown
cooper cup
okay tyree kill
i've lost all faith in nfl defenses they
all know that they need to stop all
three of those guys and they still won't
i'll go with you on that i think that if
if tyreke hill scores a touchdown that
means trouble for cincy but i'll go with
that
i'll go with that
okay
so let's let's do that cooper cup is
just i mean cooper cup has never seen
like this kid's catching double digit
responsibility defense [__] stinks
paul that's what everybody should take
away from that game
yeah
yeah stink
they had the game won they lost it they
won it they lost it they won it they
lost it they went into overtime and they
because of a [__] coin toss if their
defense goes out on that field they
[__] lose their defense [__]
stinks
if you want to understand that though
i think that all the [__] defenses
stink and they have the most offensive
weapons so i still think they're
probably going to win the whole thing
if you want to get bill burr riled up
the way that i get riled up when a home
favorite has home field and loses if you
want to get bilbo riled up talk about a
team who scores a lot of points and
their defense stinks in a praiseful way
he can't handle it
can't handle it's not football you're
right and you're right what you're
seeing is the [__] the football
version
of that bearded guy on the brooklyn nets
scoring 42 and his man gets 38. by the
way real quick just heard word out
yesterday
james harden not happy in new york or
living in brooklyn and maybe wants out
and they're saying it's because kyrie
irving only plays part-time because he
doesn't want to get the vaccine and now
mr hardin is sick of new york in
brooklyn
isn't that a shame that i was going to
blame the alt comedy scene out there in
brooklyn
[Laughter]
all right guys uh so please sign up with
bet mgm download the bet mgm app use
bonus code burr okay your first 10 bet
regardless of the outcome you're gonna
get 200 in free bets um so it's what
what can you say we've been using them
all year we love them uh bet mgm and we
will be back next week
uh oof we will be back next week with
the super bowl show so uh until then
talk to you guys soon
all right there you go
there you have it that is the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast please enjoy the music
uh picked out by the always wonderful
andrew themless and afterwards you'll
get a bonus half hour
of a thursday just before
friday monday morning podcast
from a thursday you know a year ago five
years ago i don't know how he does it
that is it
have a great weekend you [__] and i
will see you
who do you like who do you like will the
bengals shock the world who do you like
uh that's it i'll talk to you guys on
monday see you
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
january 27 2004 out of what are you
doing
um i'm out here in uh hawaii
the day after the pro bowl i brought all
my [__] i brought my mixer
i brought my cords i brought everything
that i needed except for a goddamn
microphone so i kind of got to do with
this bootleg way
um because my flight isn't until later
and uh oh look who just walked in
the lovely nia
i thought you're going to take a walk
down the beach to end your little trip
all right
all right well hey you know
don't let us stop you
all right enjoy yourself
all righty
see that she walks down the goddamn
beach and i'm sitting here slaving away
did you hear a goddamn thank you
no just kidding we had a great time out
here um but yeah our flight isn't until
later on so um
i gotta do it now so i don't have a
[__] microphone so i apologize
anyways
i am out here in hawaii i had a great
time um did a show friday night
and uh
at this this theater i remember the
[__] thing the hawaiian honolulu
center or something like that it was
really [__] cool man it was like uh
the chinese new year was going on
right next door right down the street
and i was [__] crazy
it was just sort of this artsy
cool and shady part of town and it was
night and they were lighting off those
fireworks and uh
i didn't know what it was at first and
i'm like peeking around the corners
so i'm walking down the street going
what the [__] is that
and uh because they were lighting off
like those giant cakes
of uh
firecrackers as a couple of you know
chinese dudes are walking around with
the dragon outfit on right was that
offensive i don't give a [__] it's
basically what i saw
um
not trying to disrespect your [__]
new years
um
and you know i grew up watching like
platoon
um
well well all those [__] movies there
uh
was missing in action
all of that which basically
just it was i don't know why
asians didn't complain more in the 80s
some of the [__] movies and they made
the way that they made you guys and
that's what's funny is that stuck in my
head i didn't think it was
i didn't think it was until i heard
gunpowder being lit off and i was in
this part of town that had all this you
know
asian looking stuff
all of a sudden i started feeling like
hey am i going to get stuck in a bamboo
cage with some rats and then get dragged
out mao mao is that going to happen like
i was literally feeling that which i
know to speak it out loud is ridiculous
i guess what i'm really doing here is
i'm speaking about the power of the
images that we see
on television and movies they're
corrupting our children
um i guess maybe typical i had a point
so anyways i went down there
then once i saw what was going on it was
cool as hell i got to uh
i'll show actually i'll post the video
because the video is basically me
gradually discovering what it is i mean
i kind of knew as i started to uh
um
walk down towards it i think somebody
finally had told me
and uh but it really looks like the
beginning
of either some uh oscar-winning movie
or some really creepy youtube video that
they're gonna take down soon it just
looks like something [__] up is about
ready to happen and it's actually uh
celebration so if you ever go down there
white people
and black people you know like what you
understand asians better than us you're
just as confused as we are get off your
[__] ios
when you go down there and the dragon's
doing all the goddamn thing you know
um
you know when it comes over to you stick
money in its mouth and that's supposed
to bring you good luck
i don't [__] know whatever i
participated i'm on my best behavior i'm
in a different country out here
in hawaii i don't give a [__] what they
say that this is part of america this
isn't it is but it isn't
you know what i mean
this is clearly some [__] that we took
over
where i will argue with the native
americans
um till the day i die about whether or
not we stole the country because
i gotta tell you i look around and i see
all non-native americans in the
continental united states and and
everybody looks pretty comfortable
you know they look like they fit in like
they should be there
all right
so i swear to god if one more apache
comes up to me and starts talking about
how we stole the country it's just like
well then why do i look so normal up
against this oak tree
okay
now you take
those same white people
and you stick them out here in hawaii
and we just look like we're on vacation
and people oh no i live here no no you
don't no you don't something happened
something happened and somebody lost an
arm because they couldn't find the shiny
[__] and now you have a home where that
person used to have a [__] uh hut
or some sort of [__] thing that was
made out of the ground and it was all
natural right and the rivers were nice
and clean and then we [__] showed up
i thought it was a great moment
yesterday of uh
the awfulness of uh
the direction that we've had it in it's
actually you know
i don't [__] know i'm sitting in the
upper deck of the pro bowl
because i have connections like that
and that stadium used to be
um it used to be one of those
multi-faceted stadiums whatever
multi-purpose stadiums where you played
football and baseball there and you
could like shift around the stands and
stuff like that and all this [__]
crazy stuff so of course
you know it rains out here there's all
kind of salt water in the air right so
eventually everything rusts up and the
thing can't [__] move anymore so
basically they they weld it
permanently in the football position
football position
and um
basically on each corner of the stadium
where there should be a corner you can
actually look through
and see how it's [__] hilarious you
could see all the way from the field
to the outside parking lot
to the houses in the hills all the way
up to the mountains where it was all
green and you just started at the top
and went looked all the way down to the
stadium or went the other way and you
saw
the uh the progress
of us ruining this [__] paradise out
here
um
but having said that
i actually went i'm gonna argue i went
to the most exciting pro bowl in recent
memory yesterday in case you missed it
in case you weren't one of the 40 people
who actually watched the [__] thing
um
this year what they did to try to add a
little bit of excitement to try to get
the competitive juices flowing so people
would actually [__] play the game as
opposed to playing patty cake patty cake
and falling down on the ground when
anybody was near you um
which i totally understand why the
players do it
i mean this game does not mean [__] and
they're basically well do i want to keep
making five to ten million a year
or do i want to risk that
trying to score a touchdown in this
[__] game that doesn't matter
um what they did was they had uh they
had two team captains they had jerry
rice and dion sanders and both of them
they actually had a draft
and they
you know they picked the players and all
that type of [__] and it basically came
down to the end
and uh there was a minute like 44 48
left
most of the crowd had left
uh team rice was down by seven and um i
actually i'm not going to say i was
drunk i was pretty
i was feeling pretty good and i
commentated the last
minute 44 week i got it all edited
together in a video on the podcast page
you got to watch it i'm not going to say
what happens in case you missed the
final outcome maybe you can get excited
get excited watching the video i think i
did a pretty good job
for being a little bit drunk
you know and if you take out the curses
i thought i held my own with uh you know
the jim lampleys out there
i thought it did a nice job
um by the way i also came out here i did
a little something for uh inside the nfl
i did a little pro bowl piece while i
was out here and i got to talk to some
of the players
and um
i got to uh check out the stadium and
all that type of stuff i'm not going to
do any
spoiling here but it's going to air this
week on inside the nfl on wednesday on
showtime all right and if you don't have
showtime why don't you go order it i'll
go find a friend that has it um it was
an unbelievable
unbelievable week uh
yeah i was [__] nuts i don't know how
to explain it put it this way at one
point i was actually up in the broadcast
booth before the game and i got to to
interview
uh chris collinsworth and al michaels
and they were just the greatest funniest
guys and all that type of stuff and it
just was uh
that was [__] awesome of course i
talked to elle michaels about hockey why
wouldn't i
you know and he had the exact opposite
views i had on a lot of this stuff which
was crushing me i wanted to be like yes
yes he was just like no no i feel a b
and c he's like nah d enough i'm like ah
[__] i'm an idiot
but it was awesome and uh the game was
great and i actually saw this fan i
don't know if he's a hero or an absolute
disgrace
it all depends on how you view
uh
your behavior at a game this [__]
jerk-off
somehow got himself kicked out of the
pro bowl
i i don't know even know how that
happens
everybody was so well behaved and so
psyched you're in [__] hawaii
the game doesn't mean anything
everybody's just having a great time
this guy was such a [__] maniac and
everybody else was behaving so [__]
well that i swear to god the entire
security force for the whole [__]
stadium all responded to the call i've
never seen that many cops for one guy
they actually had there was like at
least a half a dozen cops and two people
with like those white uh medical [__]
shirts on
just to kick this one idiot out
and they finally kick him out and he's
got his tattooed chick and that type of
[__] and we think they're gone long gone
blah blah which i think they kicked him
out
and evidently his chick stuck around
because with like two minutes left
this fan runs out on the field
and this is what's [__] hilarious is
how how like
how much the game doesn't mean [__]
everybody's just sort of mentally on
vacation i swear to god this woman ran
around for like 50 seconds
45 50 seconds before anybody even knew
like before you saw the first security
guy going out there
they were so busy staring at the
half-filled stands they didn't know what
we were yelling about this woman was
running
out of people she was doing that thing
you know you jump in the air and bump
into the person
she was doing that to everybody on the
field she was like running out of
players by the time they [__] came
out they were looking down there and
somebody finally goes that's that
[__] chick who's with the drunk guy
so old section was laughing at it
and
i swear to god it took him about a
minute ah she started running down the
field towards the other touchdown the
place was going nuts
it was a great time i highly highly
recommend
coming out here to the pro bowl it's a
great great great fan experience
especially if the games are going to be
like they wait the way they are now
with them uh
picking players and stuff so they
actually you know you know i'm not gonna
lie to you they weren't playing the
whole time
but they were you know moments where
they would they would you know dion i
guess was talking to the camera i didn't
see that part but was like going that's
not going to be like this and he'd amp
him up and they'd play for a couple uh
you know for the rest of the [__]
quarter or something like that but at
the end of it who gives a [__] you're in
hawaii
so anyways sorry for the [__]
meandering there what am i up to here 12
minutes 12 minutes
um
oh i got i forgot to tell you this i'm
sorry if i'm speaking a little too
quietly here because i'm in my hotel
room and i can't be screaming [__] in my
hotel
um
so anyways they actually had all like
all the mascots or a majority of them i
didn't see the patriots stupid paul
revere whatever the [__] that guy's
supposed to be
mascots at the pro bowl
so i wasn't really paying attention but
at one point all the [__] mascots are
in the end zone
and they have like a little card
with a letter on both sides which i
think you know they all line up and it
it says welcome to the pro bowl
and then they turn it over hey please
support the troops whatever the [__] it
spelled out so it was one of those deals
they spelled something then they flipped
it over and spelt something else
and then they were done
the camera shot was done and then they
just all sort of started to separate
and three mascots randomly got together
and for five seconds were standing in
the end zone spelling out jew
it was one of the funniest [__]
things i ever saw
and what's killed me was how many people
missed it because everybody because they
were down on the right hand side and the
ball was down on the left it was like a
tv timeout or something so they were
spelling out some [__] thing for the
fans and they went back the other way
and i had interviewed a couple of the
[__] mascots so i was kind of just
watching that little schtick
and uh me and the people we were with
saw it and oh my god [__] dying
dying laughing if i if i had a picture
of that that would have been the
funniest [__] ever
you know that's where those nazis have
been hiding all these years everybody's
been looking for them down in south
america and [__] brazil they've been
hiding in plain sight
dressing up as huggable [__]
baltimore ravens i think i don't want to
rat anybody else but the raven guy was
part of it i think he was holding up the
w
uh oh my god that was can you think of
anything less anti-semitic than a
[__] mascot it's just supposed to be
this lovable thing doing the worm and
the [__] moonwalk getting people
going right
sticking your [__] head in its mouth
then all of a sudden out of nowhere you
just see this ugly side of this thing
so
it was so [__] it's just like why
if you just took it seriously why would
a mascot hate jewish people
and i loved that there was no point
it just said jew
[Laughter]
oh [__] and i whatever it was [__]
funny to me let me read some advertising
here
ah christ where the hell are we
um
all right here we go all right dollar
shave club everybody dolla shave club
okay for a couple of bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com delivers amazing
quality raiders right to your front door
not only does it save you a ton of cash
it saves you from trudging to the
drugstore for a pack of blades
all right i always get stuck behind some
meth kid trying to you know
buy a uh friggin toothbrush for this one
tooth he has left in his head right but
now with dollar shave club for just a
couple bucks a month amazing quality
razors they're delivered right to your
door that's right no more wasting your
time and no more getting hit up for 20
bucks every time you go to buy razors
everybody here meaning me is getting
their dollar shave club blades and you
know what you should too
come on
if i jumped off a bridge you'd do it too
wouldn't you we'll get your damn blades
here's a genius idea try replacing your
old shaving cream with dr cava's easy
shave butter
from dollarshaveclub.com trust me your
face will thank you later
if it could speak and could think
independently
don't waste time at the drugstore behind
the lady paying it pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bar or
go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner keep your
stress level low and your bank account
balance high shave time shave money go
to dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bar
there you go look at that
that was a nice even [__] paw
i didn't go into the water i didn't go
into the [__] sand nothing
all right let's try this next one
why do i [__] feel like i have a cold
but i don't
all right nature's box
oh jesus christ nature's box i swear to
god this is what it's called we're
talking about our [__] over there
um nature
nature's box
gonna be a professional nature's box
everyone curbing your appetite doesn't
get any easier just because you went on
a diet when 3 p.m hunger pangs hit you
can you can tough it out and get cranky
and lightheaded
or you can hit the vending machine and
pack on the pounds but now there's a
third option
snack smarter in 2014 with nature's box
go down on this box of goodies this is
joke this can't be true sign up to
nature's box for great tasting
healthy snacks sent right to your door
oh nature box it's not nature's box okay
now i get it sign up to nature box
excuse me for great tasting healthy
snacks sent right to your door
well why don't you leave it at the end
of the driveway so we've burned a few
more calories and i'm not talking about
rabbit food think french toast granola
salted caramel pretzel pops and dark
cocoa almonds and more designed to leave
you full and healthy check it out now at
naturebox.com you'll find zero trans
fats zero high fructose corn syrup and
nothing artificial
and nature's box ships for free just
like nature does
right now try your first order of nature
box at fifty percent off by going to
naturebox.com
that's naturebox.com
stop the vending machine madness
snack smarter in 2014 get a handle on
your health and your hunger go to
naturebox.com
what do they have there
salted caramel pretzel pops i'm gonna
lose weight dark cocoa almonds
french toast granola
so let's see the scam here there's no
trans fats there's no high fructose corn
syrup
how about nutrition is there any
nutrition in that [__]
no jesus
yeah why wouldn't i get full eating
caramel pretzel pops yeah whatever
stamps.com everybody hey if you haven't
heard yet posted rates have changed
again
you know what that means the post office
is even more crowded than usual that's
why you need stamps.com with stamps.com
you can eliminate eliminate those time
consuming trips to the post office
everything you do at the post office you
can do right from your desk buy and
print official us postage for any letter
or package using your own computer or
printer and stamps.com always updates
the postage rates for you automatically
so you don't even have to think baby
so you'll always get the exact postage
you need the instant you need it you'll
never have to go to the post office
again unless you're dating someone over
there i've been using stamps.com for the
last couple of years it's so convenient
so easy even a [__] like me can do it
right now use my last name bur burr for
the special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer that includes a digital
scale and up to 55 bucks free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
let the baby cry get on this click on
the microphone at the top of the page
the home page and type in burp burr
that's stamps.com enter bur
well i don't know about you guys but i
think i just crushed those reeds
the nature box people are probably upset
with me but you know some i don't give a
[__] i hate when they do that stuff
little nature's nature box like this is
really healthy you know there's no trans
fats
that's like you [__] you know
drinking yourself to death and you're
going well you know there's no heroin
there's no heroin in this [__]
um
this will probably be the last week for
that read
unless you know [__] what are you gonna
do
okay let's get back to uh let's get back
to the podcast oh this week i finally
announced
um
after three people on the internet were
clamoring going when are you gonna
announce your canadian tour we actually
had the pre-sale on wednesday of last
week and it officially went on sale on
friday and i have to take time to thank
the entire
almost said continent the entire country
of canada for the unbelievable response
oh
canada you bought a bunch of tickets so
we added shows
four old red face twinkle toes
i'm gonna bring my jokes and a shiny
shirt i'll do my act for you
hey
you know what kills me is if you saw
some of the [__] god forsaken places
that i'm going on
on this canadian tour
all right
you would think that all canadians would
be happy
that i didn't just go to montreal
toronto and then go to vancouver and
then just say
oh hey i toured canada
i'm going to vancouver edmonton calgary
winnipeg toronto someplace hamilton i
don't know where the [__] that is
um
ottawa
montreal
i'm going to nova scotia i think
halifax is that what that was that's
where it is you would think they'd be
like wow thanks bill thanks for the
[__] effort you think everybody would
say that but no
only 98 percent of canadians
were that were that thankful then i got
another two percent that were giving me
[__] because i skipped over saskatchewan
right i'm going to winnipeg too
hey people in saskatchewan
i appreciate the interest but you have a
[__] stop
for two seconds
you ever think of rather than just
looking out your [__] igloo you may
be trying to look and see where i'm
coming from i live in los angeles
okay do you think i have time to go to
every goddamn province up there i'm
going out of five five you got 10
provinces out there i'm going to 5 out
of 10 of them
why can't you see
that the syrup bucket is half full
you know
i live in los angeles i have fake
titties to look at and i'm taking time
out of my nice sunny [__] winter to
go up to that [__]
moose to step around moose [__]
all right
for most of the month of march
okay and you're gonna give me [__]
because i'm not going to newfoundland
i'm not going to saskatchewan why don't
you get in your [__] pickup truck
and drive over one province
help me out
help me
help you can you do that
i'm just [__] with you actually uh
i heard your complaints
and because i'm a people pleaser
i'm actually talking to my agent right
now and we're seeing what we can do
all right
if i have time where i can [__] put
another one in there you know rather
than take a day off and get drunk and go
curling or maybe play some pond hockey
and do something that i wanted to do
you know
go up there and hang out at the celine
dion hall of fame something that i would
have found enjoyable i'm actually
looking into my schedule
okay to see if i can make it to those
[__] places and you know what's funny
i'll add those and then some kind of
yukon territory's gonna give me [__] you
know what i'm never gonna get off the
road hey here's a [__] question i
have for you
all right when you're flying
internationally
all right for any [__] international
flyers out there
when you're going from like
say like the olympic olympics are like
in what moscow this year are they're in
the ukraine
they always fly up if you're flying from
the states they fly up by greenland and
they go up to the top of the globe
also known as north
you know because the circumference is a
lot shorter up there
right and you fly over there so they can
save gas and you don't run out and fall
into the [__] ocean i get that here's
my question why don't they ever just go
up and over
just go right up and over
say if you want to go to moscow if it's
bay or beijing and it's on the opposite
side of the world why don't you just get
in a plane in chicago and fly due north
and go right up and over the [__] you
watch a couple of movies and you're
there
i was asking this question
as i always do
to non-pilots because i love to hear
what non-pilots have to say about flying
and then take their information and
present it as fact
to uh other people who aren't in the
aviating field
what does it have to do with the
magnetic pull of the planet
does it [__] with uh
your little [__] rotisseries there on
the [__] dashboard
and all of a sudden you don't know where
the ground is and where the sky is
you know what exactly is the problem
united airlines why can't you just fly
up and over
or down and under
for all my friends down there in
argentina
in australia
why can't they do that where the [__]
would you go then
hey when you fly you know
if when you fly over antarctica is there
a point where you're just upside down
i'm sorry
i was only eighty percent joking um
all right so here's a uh here's a video
there's a video that that a lot of
people sent me this week it was about
these uh these [__] banker
[__] there
um
let's see what is it here this is the
bbc news uh hsbc
imposes restrictions on large cash
withdrawals
all right and uh
so
hsbc customers have been prevented some
customers have been prevented from
withdrawing large amounts of cash
because they could not provide evidence
of why they wanted it
the bbc has learned
isn't it learned
as learnt
anyways
listeners have told radios four's money
box
not to be confused with nature's box uh
they were stopped from withdrawing
amounts ranging from five grand or five
thousand pounds to ten thousand pounds
hsbc admitted
it has not informed customers of the
change in policy policy which was
implemented in november the bank says it
has now
changed its guidance to staff
um so basically
this guy went down they said can i have
my 5 000 pounds that i earned and i put
this bank for safety they said no
he said can i have four thousand pounds
they said no and then i wrote one out
i guess one uh withdrawal slip for three
thousand pounds and they said okay we'll
give you that
um
blah blah blah blah blah so they got a
bunch of bad press and now allegedly
they're changing it so a bunch of people
said you know what the [__] with these
banker [__]
you know it's it's our money
yada yada yada and all that [__] um i
got news for you
it's not your money
all right it's their money they printed
it's theirs
okay and your job
is to take the money that they give you
for working your ass off all week and
your job is to then take that money
and give it back to him
or get your ass into debt with it
think about you work all [__] week
what do you do you even hold money in
your [__] hand anymore they give it
to you on this [__] piece of paper
all right i know a lot of people rolling
their eyes right now okay but i got a
point at the end of this [__]
okay you take it down to these [__]
and you just give it to them now this is
the thing
the reason why it's not like
the reason why they didn't give that
person the ten thousand pounds do you
know why they didn't give it to them
it's because they don't have it
i'm not saying that they don't
physically have ten thousand pounds in
the bank yes they do but they don't have
ten thousand pounds available
to give to and just some random jackass
who goes oh by the way i want to take
ten thousand pounds out right [__]
now they don't have it
well i don't know about how it works in
england but as far as in the united
states
they don't have it
for the simple fact that when
if you went down and you deposit some
regular [__] tom dick harry or louise
and you deposit 10 grand into a bank
back in the old days when there was some
sort of rules and regulations governing
these out of control [__]
when you ran a bank
you you had on your books like you could
only loan out
a certain percentage of the money
or the bank was in violation like like
say let's just say to make it easy that
a million dollars was deposited into
your bank you could only at during that
time you could only loan out i don't
know what the percentage was but it was
like 300 grand of it 400 grand
um i forget what the percentage was but
you could you could you couldn't go past
a certain tipping point because god
forbid if there was a run on money
and everybody started withdrawing
the bank would fail now any bank if
everybody shows up and tries to take the
money out is gonna fail
because
you know they they they loan out a
certain percentage of it all right but
throughout the years they kept pushing
that percentage up more and more and
more and more
to the point that they got up to not
only can they loan out a hundred percent
of the deposits from the hard work and
the people that deposit the money in
there they can actually then create
another two million dollars off that
million something like that like so if
you deposit 10 grand they can take your
full 10 grand loan it out
plus another 10 grand off that 10 grand
so they basically just invented
slash counterfeited 20 grand that didn't
even [__] exist off that 10 grand
they got 30 grand loaned out
so they can make the money off that
[__] 20 percent interest off of that
kicking you half a percent in your
[__] account and they just sit there
knowing full well at some point whatever
bubble they're creating is going to
burst [__] is going to hit the fan
you're going to be ass out and they're
too big to fail and it worst case
scenario that you're going after a
corporation and what are they they're
just they're just they're faceless
corporation is faceless they take their
bonuses
it's just sitting there waiting for john
cougar mellencamp to write you a [__]
song
that [__] jackass aid and they're out
there buying a new [__] yacht
all right did that make sense
and i know you guys are going to be like
girl you're full of [__] blah blah blah
you don't know what the [__] you're
talking about you sound like a [__] hey
i'll take all of that but i'm going to
tell you this for like the [__] 100th
time in my stand-up career when i was in
albuquerque i had a banker come up to me
and was laughing going i know you hate
us and i said listen am i a [__] in the
podcast and they always say no
they go no you're not
you know this of some factual errors a
little bit here or there but basically
what you're saying is 100 true
i talk conspiracy theory one time in my
own bank
as i was trying to set something up new
on my account i was talking to a banker
about conspiracy theory
and he was talking about banking he was
talking about how scary and [__] up it
was and he was asking me what i planned
to do
what do you think about gold and silver
coins what do you think about growing
zucchini and i i was the most techies
whispering and [__] i'm telling you
um
and i have no solution so what i'm
really being right now is a [__] fear
monger
but uh this is this is the the great
thing about banking is that you know i
would say a good 95 percent of people
walking around with a [__] goddamn
tootsie pop in their mouth pulling their
[__] hawaiian shorts out of their ass
crack
believe in it
all right and as long as they continue
to believe in it
you can kind of exist in the game
drafting behind
their um
uninformed
i don't know what the [__] word is
i'm so i'm too stupid to do this but you
just basically like
i don't know
i i am of the belief that if you can get
a [__] house
buy one that you can afford and then pay
that [__] down as soon as you can and
all of that [__]
that people say where they go oh it's
not an investment because you go to
dude [__] that
pay off your [__] house and then if
the bank fails you still have a house
who gives a [__]
if you paid 700 grand for it now it's
only worth a hundred grand
you still have a house
as much as that sucks
at least you still have it
like the [__] stock market right
you work your whole goddamn life you
stick it in that stick it in this over
there and you think you're being
conservative the thing shits the bed
and in the end you can be left with
nothing
so i am into tan
tangible [__] can you tell i screamed
whenever i do a podcast the day after i
went to a game or i did a lot of shows i
sound like i'm going through puberty
again i apologize
but um
i believe in investing in tangible [__]
and don't let your wife or your husband
be like oh we got kids we go we're going
to shave up with their college education
you know what [__] that college
education
all right
take out a loan
take out a [__] you're paying
interest on your house now the amount of
money that you're going to save knocking
down your principal will pay
for most if not all of their college
education
all right unless they just go to some
unbelievably expensive school and you're
i don't know living in some little house
on the prairie
michael landon smoking a pipe
um
so there you go so that's why that's why
when they go down there
because they they're not going to give
10 grand or 10 pounds to the average
jackass walking in there
because that starts [__] with their
game which is pretending that all the
money is there and that it's it's safe
and that there's nothing to worry about
and nothing to see here so what they do
is they pull this [__] and they bully
people individually over in the corner
behind that bulletproof glass
and they're like no you have to get a
note and blah blah blah blah and most
people
like
they
have a
parent-child relationship their entire
life
they come out as a child
their parents tell them what to do what
they can and can't do when they can eat
when they have to go to bed and they go
off into the world
you know you go to school
we're going to lunch now if you have a
question raise your hand
you stay in that mentality so to the
point you have a [__] adult who
earned the money
will go into a bank
you know god bless this person who
actually [__] was like no this is my
money and complained and brought this
out to light but do you think this is
the only person they did that to
the money's not there man
yeah like if you had like two three
hundred grand
in an account you decide that you just
want to [__] take it out like
if you physically want the money
if you want to transfer it like [__]
numbers hit enter they'll [__] do
that all day oh yeah no worries
but if you actually wanted the paper
like you can't just walk in there and be
like yes i'd like my 300 grand
and they'd be like oh okay
and come out with big sacks of money you
got to call them days if not a week in
advance
and then what they got to do is
frantically call around
in front find an armored car
with enough of this paper
that isn't worth [__] other than the
fact that the guy with the underwear in
his ass still believes in it they got to
drive that there so they can physically
keep the lie going
all right
there you go so that's the end of my
my [__] uh bar room
banking 101
all right and uh you know i don't give a
[__] about your opinions either
because i'm not enlightened as a human
being if you don't agree with what i
said then you know just laugh at me and
continue on with your [__] day
because uh you're actually helping me
out
as long as you keep [__] believing in
it
but
i think the day
the wave hitting the beach is coming
soon because uh you know at least in
this country
i mean the government shut down for
three [__] days
and i know made for great stand-up
material but that is absolutely [__]
terrifying
every year when august comes around
and we hit the debt ceiling and we just
keep raising it
and we just keep pushing more of [__]
under the bed
like eventually it's not all i don't
know that's probably the wrong analogy i
don't know what the [__] we're doing but
eventually the [__] is gonna hit the fan
so uh
i'm not saying i'm gonna survive it
whatever the [__] happens but i do have
a game plan
my game plan is to pay off my house as
quickly as i can
so when the first wave of people are
being brought to the uh
i don't know what euphemism they're
going to be using for detention camps
um
i figured it'll be like well you can't
pay off your house for repossessing the
house so now we're going to move you to
alternative relaxing living whatever the
[__] they're gonna call it at least i
won't be in that first wave of people
i will have
my house paid off and i will stand there
dressed like a court jester with my
little fancy cane
going but get off my property and
they'll look at me and be like oh look
at this little [__] thinking he has
power all right we'll be back for you
we'll be back for you like a month or so
let's just get the uh
let's get the mouth breathers first
let's get the easy people then we'll
weed out the red [__] and then it'll
all be ours
some it somehow ties in to how they're
trying to make robots
more and more human-like
all right this is the kind of [__] this
story right here
that seems like a victory
for the common man and what it really is
is it's just moving the ball forward on
the development of robots so they can
eventually phase us out um and then they
can just have robot people that will
never never complain
then of course if you watch science
fiction movies they somehow
take over the humans which they're not
gonna do
they're not gonna do that all right we
made you
all right
we'll unplug you
we won't fix you
i'll dump some water on you
you know
this is the deal every [__] web
designer when he builds your website or
he builds you a secure site always
builds in a [__] back door
all right so the guys making the robots
are gonna do the same [__] thing
there's no way the illuminati is gonna
have a bunch of robots that are stronger
than them don't need to sleep and all
that type of [__] and like they watch
science fiction movies these [__] are
science fiction
how crazy do i sound this week i'm
actually enjoying every [__] second
of this
um
they're gonna have a back door you know
somewhere up that
robot's ass there's got to be something
that they can [__] do
some button they have to push
um all right so there you go was that
weird enough for you
huh
i'm sorry
what do you want from me you know i'm a
[__] weird guy how about some more
let me let me bring it back to earth
with a [__] commercial
all right legalzoom everyone
you know some things like starting your
own business or protecting your family
with a will
aren't like your other new year's
resolutions you can't afford to blow
them off instead of less snacking and
more exercise put those things that i
just said at the top of your list i
still think that that's written
incorrectly that's why i tried to improv
improv my way through that legal zoom
helps you incorp what they're really
trying to say instead of watching your
waistline and exercising which are great
things you might want to consider having
a will all right in case you get hit by
a bus
you know when somebody takes you this
all the stuff off your mantle
and your kids don't get it instead of
whatever over uh one million
entrepreneurs have done it and ninety
percent of customers recommend legal
zoom to friends and family you can also
create a will starting at just sixty
nine dollars or even even a living trust
quickly and easily and get peace of mind
and protection no surprise fees no
hassles man no headaches legal zones
step-by-step process was created by a
team of experts in law and technology
legalzoom is not a law firm but can
connect you with the third party
attorney and provide you with self-help
services
from wills to business formations
trademarks powers of attorney and more
go to legalzoom.com for even more
savings type in burp b-u-r-r into the
referral box at checkout don't put off
things you need to do today go to
legalzoom.com now and use the discount
code burr that's legalzoom.com discount
code burr
oh geez i'm just hitting the fairways
today guys
i'm not saying i'm not too putting but
i'm doing all right here all right
e-voice
you are a business owner but autumn but
an automated phone system and
secretaries are not in your budget just
yet and juggling incoming calls yourself
makes it pretty hard to look like a
professional
right well here's something that will
drastically help or dramatically help
you more with my uh with your money in
2014 it's e-voice everybody whether
you're a business of one or one hundred
e-voice will help you manage all of your
incoming calls with a toll-free number
dial by name directory and call routing
tools your business will sound like a
million bucks you can't take the call no
problem e-voice will transcribe the
voicemail and email it right to you
never be caught off guard again and with
e-voice you can try it before you buy it
right now just for my listeners you can
get a 60-day trial to e-voice absolutely
free go to evoice.com and enter the
promo code bill at checkout take a trip
uh sorry take charge of your business
and make more money in 2014 go to
evoice.com and enter bill at checkout
for your 60-day free trial that's
evoice.com promo code bill
you know i [__] up there in the ending
because i swear to god that nature box
was really bothering me
you know
i'm going to talk to those guys i'm
going to find out more about what
they're putting in nature's box there
because i'm not going to sell you guys
a bunch of [__]
that's not even healthy for you but beca
you know that looks like one of those
fad diet you know what you just eat a
[__] banana
okay
what is a banana 25 cents
35 cents in new york with a 50 cents now
gives a [__] eat a goddamn banana
have an apple
it's fiber it's going to fill you up
have a giant salad you know what you
need to do and you're just being lazy
and rather than doing that
okay because your body's craving sugar
and salt you're thinking that you want
to eat [__] caramel pretzel
[__] cakes whatever the [__] they're
selling you don't what you need to do is
you need to [__]
you need to get a goddamn salad
you need to get that in your body and
then your body will crave that your body
will crave nutrition and it's the
greatest [__] thing ever if you
actually read up on nutrition
which i have only kind of done and it's
helped me immensely but if you guys you
know
there's no way you're gonna be dumber
than i am if you actually read up on
nutrition you don't even [__] if you
go for walks
you don't need to go to the gym
if you just did push-ups and some
pull-ups and you ate a balanced
nutrition diet
nutrition nutritional diet
you know what the
goddamn [__]
snickerdoodle that looks like a
chocolate colored covered [__] apple
i i i hate that [__] all right
i just have a [__] old roommate of
mine used to do that all the time and
you'll know who it is by the impression
you know
no i'm not going to do it but this
person used to [__] go on these god
used to one time he's on this diet he
was drinking like this chocolate shake
three times a day
three times a [__] day this dude is
drinking a goddamn chocolate
shake
to lose weight
oh it's chocolate favorite [__]
powder
oh yeah i'm sure that's not i'm sure
that's great for your waistline but i
can imagine that's doing something else
[__] up would you look at what you're
you're putting in your body
you [__] [__] ah it's just ah not
[__] what are you gonna do hey you know
drink your [__] powdered milk i don't
give a [__]
die sooner and uh you know the rivers
are cleaner
all right where do i go from here yo
last week you know what i forgot to
bring up i had such a busy week
um i went to the uh
hang on a second now what the [__] did i
just do there
i gotta make sure oh
all right hang on a second
i know it sounds weird right
i'm now look this up here
make sure i get this right get the dates
right and everything
um
all right last week i forgot to mention
that i went to the uh
now why the [__]
come on now canal comes up all right
this happens once a week on the podcast
if you're new to it by the way i always
go to look something up and of course my
computer doesn't even [__] work um
anyways i went to the uh the common
thread
clinic tour which is a drum clinic for
all you drummers out there if you just
want to watch three absolute [__]
beasts
on the drums
with three totally different styles
um and what's really cool is they're
actually all seven years apart that's
what they said one's 23 once 30 once 37
and
it was just an absolutely incredible
tour that i ended up going to because i
was following mike johnston who i've
talked about here
mikeslessons.com
and uh he's on tour with matt halpern
and uh jp bouvet i hope i said that
right
flunk french for so many goddamn years
absolutely amazing um
amazing amazing drummers so as far as
the tour that i see uh looks like
they're off right now but they're gonna
maybe start back up in april i hope i'm
saying this right
um you can look it up on facebook the
common thread clinic tour
april 18th 19th 20th 22 23 25 they're
good this is basically going to be
lancaster pennsylvania on the 18th
uh
they're going to be in deptford township
new jersey on april 19th asbury park new
jersey on the 20th manhattan new york
sam ash the 22nd
uh middletown new york on the 23rd
manhattan new york drummer's collective
april 25th i used to take drum lessons
there place is awesome anyways
um if you're a drummer or even just a
musician like they gave just great
advice on how to get better and how to
actually make a living as a musician was
absolutely
[__] mind-blowing amazing
um drum clinic and one of the coolest
things is all three of them are up there
at the same time so they kind of draw
out of a hat who's gonna solo first
and one of the coolest thing other than
listening and watching the drum solo is
watching the other two drummers
watching who's ever playing and you
watch them learning stuff and kind of
looking at each other smiling when they
see
whatever cool fill or something like
that it was it was [__] awesome can't
say enough great things about it so uh
you know we'll have the link up on the
podcast page for the common thread
uh clinic tour hope you guys get to
check it out or even just like [__]
drums you know there's it works on so
many levels if you want to make a dream
come true it actually works on that
[__] level
um
if you know how to just apply it and
what kills me about watching these guys
getting better talking about getting
better as drummers this it's the exact
same
like
process as getting to get better as a uh
a comedian or even like an athlete you
know finding a weakness working on a
weakness you know sticking with it
you know being open being positive
networking with people it's all the same
the exact same thing it was really
[__] mind-blowing so uh check it out
if you get a chance
and with
that we are one week away not even one
week away from the super bowl everybody
and um
i actually thought that all they were
gonna do is talking about that sherman
guy
and uh evidently i guess all they've
been talking about is the weather i
don't you know i haven't been paying
attention but uh
you know i did that thing this week
and i talked to a lot of football guys
and people just kept bringing up the
weather i don't understand what is the
big [__] deal
that it's in new york city
football fans like i don't understand uh
why are they tough right up until the
the afc and nfc championship games
and they could sit in snow
you know did anybody die at the green
bay packer game it was like [__]
minus 20 whatever it was it was fine
they're football fans
why are they making such a big [__]
deal if it snows in the super bowl and
you know what it is
from what i've heard it's because so
many [__] haberdashery [__] who
don't even give a [__]
these corporate people who want to show
up in their wing tips and their [__]
ties
you know
any [__] sushi and all that [__]
during the game that's the big deal
that's the big deal because i'm sitting
there thinking like this is [__]
great one of the great nfl films of all
time is when they show uh
that green bay dallas cowboys game
up in lambeau field the frozen tundra
right people are to be fine
there's no problem stop acting like
regular people are nervous about a
little bit of [__] snow
i think it's going to be great
it's about time why do they always got
to play around a bunch of palm trees i
fight [__] you know something i
[__] hate the super bowl
i love that it's for the championship
but i i hate all the how much more [__]
can they add to it
jesus [__] christ
not one band you got two bands you got
all the stupid commercials
you know i said last week to just let
the game go like take the game let it go
90 minutes before you start i would
actually go a full two hours this year
with all of the goddamn crap
i'm a grumpy old man all right
let's plow forward um and somebody give
that guy sherman a hug
okay i know he's acting all confident
and everything but i'm telling you that
guy needs a hug
he needs a hug and please tell him that
he's the best everything in the world
i'm calling it right now
calling right now that guy will
eventually
break down and cry in an interview
he's going to there will be the softer
side
of uh whatever his first name is sherman
i swear to god
i've seen it before i called it when i
saw rex ryan walking around
sticking out his [__]
his man tits talking all this [__]
i'm telling you that guy cries himself
to sleep with a bowl of ice cream
you know
his wife rubs his head every night
telling him it's it's going to be okay
[Laughter]
i'm just [__] with rex right i
actually think he's a great coach and he
actually hasn't talked any [__] in a
couple years but he hasn't had a team
where he could
so i think it's very easy for him to be
behaving himself so we'll see who the
[__] knows what who am i to judge him
right
all right
okay let's get into the emails for the
week paul pierce's return to boston
a uh billy leaf clover i just left the
td bank north garden not sure if you had
any hotel sports center time whilst in
hawaii but pierce made his return
tonight it was really special the
consensus was that no one
no other boston athlete has received as
warm or welcome as pierce would
uh having been there i gotta say it's
the truth no pun intended men were
crying kids who didn't grow up watching
watching him knew he was something
special by the way it felt in there
tonight no one played harder night after
night for over a decade and even while
no
even while no one was watching tuesday
night games against the raptors at the
end of a losing losing season and he
would still play his heart out it was
really amazing the link is below
uh for the video from the game i
actually watched it yeah it was amazing
uh
celtics fan
treated him right when he came back um
yeah i mean that reminded me of the
standing ovation that bobby orr got when
he came back when larry bird uh retired
i mean that was right up there with um
with everybody and i think that's such a
great thing
when fans uh
show their appreciation like that so i'm
psyched seemed like obviously paul
pierce was really moved
and that type of thing and he's
definitely he's going to be up there
there i think they're going to retire
his number they have to they have to
he's one of the greats so uh
if you didn't get a chance we'll have
that link i got a lot i'm promising a
lot of links this week everybody
okay did i mention that i i i mentioned
that i commentated the last minute 45 of
the pro bowl that's the one i'm looking
forward to hearing your reaction to
because uh i'm about me not paul pierce
i'm a selfish entertainer
all right
uh bill my friend wants to be you
dear freckled avenger
i have a problem
ever since one of my buddies started
listening to you he started trying to
act exactly like you he started using a
fake boston accent he changes his
opinion opinions according to the weekly
podcast i know because i listen to the
show and i can hear his opinions change
during our conversations on tuesday
morning also he roots for all boston
sports teams now the only thing he
hasn't done is dye his [__] hair red
i don't want to be the [__]
i don't want to be the [__] calls
them out and ruins the friendship could
you please say a few words about this
thanks and go [__] yourself
well listen pal
you know
it's long been stated that i am the
taylor swift of podcasting
all right
little boys and girls look up to me they
want to be me
they play dress-up
yeah i don't know what to do with this
[__] email whatever he seems like
he's enjoying it to another level i like
that he's a fan of all boston teams
right now and i'm kind of enjoying that
it's ruining your life
i actually wish i didn't read this i
wonder if he's listening right now and
can actually tell
that your that his own friend wrote this
this is [__] weird
i'm right in the middle of it
um
is he going to get a [__] patriots
jersey that says freckled avenger on the
back of it no
and what kind of friend do you man why
why can't you just let him have his fun
people need heroes
why can't i be a hero to somebody
you know
you know what i want to do i want that
dude to come out to a comedy show when
he laughs at one of my jokes i want to
do that taylor swift thing and i'll look
over in his
direction
and i'll just whisper
oh my god
did you ever see that thing on 60
minutes
when she she would look into the upper
deck when all these girls were screaming
and she would get this weird look on her
face and then she would whisper oh my
god
and it was just this totally calculated
thing to try to make it appear that she
was so blown away
by their uh show of affection but what
it really seemed like
the look on her face and then the fact
she was saying oh my god she actually
looked like
she looked like she was thinking like i
thought i already killed those little
bastards
they're back again oh my god
i have to [__] poison them again um
well there you go everybody i have my
first um
single
what is it single white male
maybe we'll do a remake of the movie
hey you know what in that movie that
chick was a redhead right
yeah jesus all right dutch girlfriend
turns out to be a hooker
oh man
i feel bad for you but i don't feel bad
for you provided you didn't get an std
and you didn't knock her up
oh jesus all right
let's put on some latex and wade into
this one everybody
dear bill
i live in the netherlands
um i've been casually seeing this girl
for a few months her family is rich
she's a pro fashion model and looks like
bridgette bardot
i've heard that name but i can't picture
the face but with a name like that right
she's got to be all stuck up huh with
her [__] perfect jeans
anyways yesterday she told me that for
the past few months she's been working
as a [__]
how [__] up am i that actually find
that sexy on some level um high class on
account of her looks and profession 2
000 euros for three hours 10 000 euros
for 24 hours oh my god
oh my god some guy slobbered all over
for 10 thousand hours how quickly did
you have to break up with this girl
i should make fun of this this is
terrible why why is she tapping out
she's taking the easy way out here
you're already a model everybody's rich
is she getting written out of the will
she's freaking out like what do i do
i've been rich my whole life now i'm not
going to be i'll suck it
uh well why don't i read when i continue
reading here the usual clientele is rich
corporate [__] and idiots who save
up and think paying ludicrous amounts of
money
will get them a better orgasm
i have absolutely no interest in seeing
this girl anymore she's not going to be
the mother of my children yeah no she's
not
yet she's only told four other people
if i split after her telling me this
secret she'll feel like a piece of trash
and view me like some puritan ass wipe
my real reason for running away is you
can't ask her to quit and if she does
she'll only resent you for it and be at
risk of relapsing any time i gotta get
out how do i do it well well what you
have to do is stop being concerned about
her feelings
what about your feelings what about the
fact that this woman is [__] around
on you what about the fact that she
could give you an std what about the
fact that she that a relationship is
built on trust and she has this giant
[__] secret
arguably the biggest [__] secret you
could have
you know
i'm not judging anybody in this [__]
story
because i've been you and i've been the
[__]
i'm just saying
from the [__] i exp i accept to get i
expected to get [__] dumped
you know
there's plenty of manors out there you
know that's what happens
um
yeah dude no you got to stop thinking
about like it's weird like this is what
you have to do you you have to get over
the um
you have to be selfish in a [__]
relationship to end up getting what you
want in life all right
and you have to have parameters
and
you know to use the cliche you know to
make an omelet you got to break some
eggs that's basically what you got to do
and this is not your fault
um
i don't know what happened her that made
her choose this horrific [__]
profession
but
it's not your fault and it's not your
job to fix it
and um you said it in your last two
sentences i gotta get out
how do i do it uh so i guess your second
last sentence you said it i gotta get
out so
you just have you don't have to be mean
about it you just have to say listen
that's just a uh
unbelievable
piece of information you just gave me
that you were keeping from me and uh
jesus christ you just got you gotta use
the cliche you know relationships built
on trust
you know i'm not judging you
uh i wish you weren't you know what
there's a part of her that might want
is probably i don't even tell you this
because you might run to this because
it's easier but like
you know
i don't know this is what i would do i
would break up with her and then also
try to get her help to get her out of it
that's what i would do
and by getting her help i would give her
information where she can go
she needs to handle this on her own
because you have feelings for her and
you know that this isn't the mother of
your kids and if you just keep hanging
around there you're going to get sucked
back into it again and now you have to
trust somebody who lied to you at that
[__] level
and um
that is just a a
[__] train wreck waiting to happen
all right dude i would go get myself
tested for everything on the under the
[__] sun
and um
that's it
that's it and if she cries i mean that's
part of it
and she brought it on herself it's not
your fault
all right and i'm not trying to be mean
or whatever
i mean i don't know what happened to her
that made her do that type of [__] but
that's not your fault okay so why don't
you go out there find a great girl who
isn't a [__] on the side
and go
live your dreams all right and you know
what you're going to dump her it's going
to hurt for a little while
even though you knew it was the right
thing to do it's still supposed to hurt
because you're a human being you just
gotta push through that
go to the gym
right
have a couple of belts at the bar
but just stay in it
stay in that pain and you wait till that
pain is gone and then you [__] go out
and try to find somebody else
in the meantime you rub one out all
right
[Laughter]
okay ordain my wedding
hey bill i'm getting married in october
yes
i'm getting in that line to lose half my
[__] well hey welcome to the club so did
i
uh strange request
uh but would you ordain my wedding or at
least be my best man
uh what does ordained me
you want me to go dude we are gathered
here today
to join these two people in holy
matrimony
under the eyes of god
in front of the church
next to you
your [__] busted aspirated tube there
um
yeah what kind of a man invites another
man to a [__] wedding don't ever do
that to me again okay i'll look past it
one time why the [__] would i want to go
to a wedding
you know actually you know what the
reason why i didn't like to go to
weddings in the past because it put
pressure on my relationship now that we
finally got married there's no [__]
pressure we're going to a married uh
married we're going to a wedding coming
up and i'm [__] psyched
you know
i already did it i don't have a [__]
problem he's sitting there eating
[__] hors d'oeuvres
dancing to the locomotion whatever the
[__] it is just getting hammered i'm
gonna have a great [__] time for the
first time you know what i might do
where is your wedding if i got a gig in
the area
if i got a gig in the area i might come
over there
tell me where it is
who knows
stranger things have happened but then
if i do yours then i gotta do
everybody's
right can i sell my dvds at the end of
your wedding
try out a couple of bits
um anyways mit
massachusetts inch
technology creates toughest tongue
twister ever
dear bill literate
oh you [__] [__] that's a great one
um
thanks for the show
you are amazing look at that this person
is buttering me up to make a complete
ass of me we all love the podcast and by
far the best part is listening to you
attempt to read spots and emails yeah
that's because you're not happy or
confident in your own life that you have
to watch somebody else fail
that's what it is what does that say
about that says more about you than it
says about me all right
you guys are my real friends
um mit recently created what they think
is the toughest tongue twister ever give
it a shot
this is what they're doing at mit
i couldn't get accepted there
if you can say it 10 times fast you get
a prize
oh go [__] yourself what am i at goddamn
dancing monkey
what is it
pad kid
that's not even a that doesn't even make
sense pad kid poured curd pulled cod
shouldn't be that kid that kid poured
curd pulled cod
pad kid poured curd pulled caught ah go
[__] yourself is this am i actually
saying something dirty and i can't hear
it right now
i don't [__] know
all right for those who have absolutely
no life if you want to [__] try and
do that i you know
have fun okay book recommendation
um what are we up to here oh hour and
seven minutes beautiful hey
hey billy burgundy balls
heard you mentioned that no country for
old men is one of your favorite movies
mine too if you're looking for any good
books to read i highly recommend
anything by carmack mccarthy i hope i
said that right carmack c a r m a c one
word mccarthy m a
lowercase c a r t h y author of no
country carmack mccarthy oh he wrote
that i actually want to read the book no
country of old man uh he said i read
said book after i saw the movie and even
though they did a great job with the
movie the book was still incredible
everything i've read for him was
top-notch the border trilogy probably
being my favorite if you hate easy
going light on your loafer stories with
predictable happy endings you'll dig his
[__] come to indianapolis and go [__]
yourself sir i came there last april um
all right you know what i will check
that out
i like it i might i might you know what
i'm gonna do you know what i'm gonna do
people i'm gonna go to my website click
on the podcast page and then i'm going
to click on the amazon banner
in the corner which is going to take me
to amazon because when you go to amazon
through us here at billboard.com
it doesn't cost you any extra money
cost you an extra click of your finger
and um
well you know whatever they you you know
you buy whatever you buy and then they
kick it back to me
they give me a little bit of a kickback
that's what they do and then i take that
money and i give it to a charity that
isn't corrupt hopefully
like the last one i was giving to which
evidently people saying is not exactly
on the up and up so now i gotta switch
it to something else
what kind of a [__] person does it
starts a goddamn charity get you all
[__] excited about it you think
you're making it
you know
and it's right up there with that pink
lady man she's got her day and [__]
something is coming i'd like to think
i would like to think okay so anyways um
i guess that's the podcast for this week
once again everybody check out the
common thread clinic tour
and uh all these guys are monster
drummers and really unbelievable uh
educators and drums and i'm telling you
they got websites they got all kinds of
stuff
they got stuff to get your bands going
and just all kinds of information was
phenomenal um
anyways that is the podcast for this
this week i'm trying to think where am i
going to be next next thing i'm doing is
i'm doing a a casino gig in minnesota on
february 7th
it's just outside of minneapolis i have
all the dates and all the proper links
up on my website billboard.com and once
again i know i was given the people in
saskatchewan [__] i'm going to try to
get out there uh i really i absolutely
blown away
blown away by the response to uh me
finally touring canada up there and uh
i'm going to be bringing the lumber
all right so i'll see you guys in a
couple of months i got a nice run of
dates going through jersey down into
maryland and into virginia also in
february
and we got the uh patrice o'neal
second annual i'm so proud to say that
the second annual patrice o'neill comedy
benefit
on february 18th in new york city it's
already sold out
but uh there are going to be ways that
if you would like to contribute that we
will have i'm actually thinking about
starting up an email where i can uh
you know get some more pictures of
patrice with maybe some you know some
fan photos that he took after i know he
used to like going out and talking to
people
and uh
i'm just really proud that we're doing
it again this year helping out all the
people that he was helping out
and um
keeping the memory of uh
the most amazing comic i ever saw live
and that's not it that's not
i'm not exaggerating like this guy you
know anything i highly recommend any
[__] thing that you can watch on
youtube or download or anything buy your
specials
uh if you have any sort of appreciation
for comedy or just art in general he was
he was the best he made all of us look
like
little kids so uh the second annual one
and i i hope to be doing this for as
long as i'm around is going to be on
february 18th and like i said we'll try
to get some merch together we're trying
to figure out what the [__] we're gonna
do for uh the fans that couldn't make it
there that want to donate
uh maybe have a donating button maybe
bill maybe you could just figure out
what the [__] it is instead of trying to
brainstorm on your podcast all right go
[__] yourselves i'll talk to you next
week oh super bowl prediction
i said it last week i'm going to say it
again this week i think uh
oh man i think i got to go with seattle
there's something there's something
about [__] denver
and how john elway at the end of his
career solidified
his name in history
by [__] uh winning those last two and
now i don't know something weird that
peyton is playing for the broncos that's
the only thing that's making me nervous
but i think the difference in the game
is going to be marshawn lynch and i
think denver is going to do a good job
in the first half
of doing you know the best you can to
contain that unbelievable talent but i
think that they're going to wear them
down i thought that denver's defense
looked a little
i don't know if they were tired or what
but i was not
liking the fact if i'm a betting man the
way they let san diego and new england
hang around even after they totally
[__] dominated them
for the first two three or quarters so i
think marshawn lynch is going to be the
difference he's going to chew up some
clock
and uh peyton manning's going to be
standing there on the sidelines
with that look on his face like you got
to be [__] [__] me not again um
but having said that i actually really
like both teams and um
i actually all the [__] i've talked
about peyton over the years
you know really sticking up for brady
made me not like peyton you know it's
not like i know the guy i actually
would love to see him win another one
but i would also like to finally see
seattle's fans actually have something
to cheer about loudly
like a championship as opposed to that
we're the best dressed we're the most
spirited with the loudest [__]
horseshit that they have started and you
did start that
okay so know that
know that that you started that
and when you see it in the future that
it started in your [__] coffee making
goddamn city
oh by the way did anybody see and this
is why i don't like that sherman talking
[__] [__] horseshit
after a game i really i i'm that old
white guy that thinks it's absolutely
classic classless um did i say right
classless
and
and just what it teaches children
and i can tell you right now did anybody
see that justin bieber
video of him playing one-on-one
with his black friend that he paid to
lose during the youtube video did
anybody watch that
i can't even remember the [__] i saw it
i can't remember if it was on the news
or if i watched it online
but he sinks a shot he's filming himself
he sinks a shot
and he turns around
and gives this look
to the video camera as he walks all the
way back
to take the ball out again if you see
the look on this [__]
140 pound jackasses face
and i can't even get mad at him he
learned it by watching these [__]
idiots who hit layups
and you know thump that chest and do
that 300
[__] yell after everything that they
do
it's the dumbest
people literally fighting in wars like
[__] rambo taking out three people at
once after they do that
they don't [__] turn around and give
a look
why i don't you hit a [__] the kid
hits like a 10-footer
turns around and he looks like he's like
just like i never even saw jordan do
that
he stared down some people absolutely
but after what he dunked on patrick
ewing and some other six foot ten guy
that's what i don't like about it
and i see it just
the kids they learn it and then all of a
sudden they're playing the [__] game
and i gotta sit there and every time
somebody hits a layup or catches a
four-yard pass for a first down they
gotta act like they reinvented the game
and i never saw jerry rice wayne gretzky
i mean i've seen some magic johnson i
never saw do that
jesus christ act like you [__] been
there before you goddamn idiots i i
don't know i swear to god
if everybody starts doing it i'm going
to get into needlepoint all right
you know what maybe that'll calm me down
maybe it'll help me with my [__]
temper
all right i'll talk to you next week go
[__] yourself